[Musique]
l'un des exemples les plus frappants de
ce que certains appellent ici
l'optimisme aveugle du gouvernement big
n
pour bien saisir l'ampleur du débat sur
la syndicalisation des pêcheurs en
nouvelle écosse ce serait l'ironie
suprême si monsieur mulroney réussissait
à convaincre monsieur de siéger au sénat
parce que ce rapport soit une façon de
donner un signal aux canadiens qu'il
faut faire quelque chose
il ya d'abord eu comme ça que je fais
dans mon budget pour
l'intense de 30 converse conjoint michel
bonsoir en a il viendra maintenant à
d'autres juges de décider s'il s'agit là
d'une erreur en droit nous voici sur
deux lignes de front dans une franche
qui sépare les talibans de l'alliance du
nord
on pensait pas que c'était probable que
la foulée réussissent à se rendre au
parlement qui était quand même gardé par
des centaines de policiers
l'autre question est de savoir si
vladimir poutine va se servir de ce
second mandat pour concentrer davantage
de pouvoirs au kremlin ici à ramallah la
foule a envahi l'esplanade de la
mouqataa husa enterré yasser arafat
michel tomi radio canada
il est au service de l'information et
des canadiens depuis 33 ans
michel cormier en a fait du chemin pour
comprendre et expliquer les faits
essentiels et marquants de l'actualité
d'ici et d'ailleurs
directeur de l'information de
radio-canada depuis 2012
il part demain à la retraite après une
carrière qui considèrent béni des dieux
à la veille de son départ il m'a accordé
cette entrevue michel gomis toujours un
exercice assez délicat d'interviewer
quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien parce qu en
toute transparence il faut dire qu'on a
longtemps travaillé ensemble j'étais
réalisatrice avec vous sur le terrain
parce qu'avant de devenir directeur de
l'information vous avez une longue
carrière de journaliste sur les colline
parlementaire à ottawa à québec à
l'étranger aussi
d'abord j'aimerais revenir un peu sur
ces années là si je vous demandais les
moments marquants de cette époque là
d'abord peut-être sur la colline
parlementaire à ottawa qu'est ce qu'ils
vont bien en tête surtout moi j'ai vécu
les grandes allées de politique à ottawa
le lac meech la création du bloc la
démission du sien bouchard le référendum
dans 95 donc c'était des années 60 est
que le canada était romand à la croisée
des chemins
donc c'était des années complètement
fébrile stimulante et moi j'ai travaillé
à la fois pour le réseau anglais ensuite
pour le réseau français donc j'avais un
point de vue si on veut assez assez
unique d'un sens où je pouvais
interpréter un peu le québec pour un
auditoire anglophone et après
interpréter un petit peu aussi comment
se sentait le canada anglais pour un
auditoire de radio canada
vous avez été l'interprète des deux
solitudes ensemble d'outils et par la
suite vous êtes partis à l'étranger vous
avez fait carrière dans à moscou à paris
à pékin des moments marquants de cette
période laisse que si je vous demande
une couverture peut-être qui vise à
transformer comme journaliste pendant
cette période la messe haïti ça a été la
guerre en afghanistan
j'ai traversé la frontière du
tadjikistan et de là vers nice temps
deux semaines après les attentats de new
york donc et on a abouti dans le village
où masud le grand chef rebelle avait été
assassiné le même vécu dans la maison de
massoud et cette couverture l'homme a
changé parce que pour la première fois
j'étais vraiment devant la vie à ce
qu'on est à brut et on ne savait pas si
elle est passée c'est un pays qui est en
guerre il fallait trouver des sujets il
incarne et à travers des gens qui
vivaient cette situation là et ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a frappé à l'époque c'est à
quel point les choses sont compliquées
parce qu'il y avait des moudjahidine
avait des guerriers qui étaient des
alliés des etats unis contre les
talibans est au complet
au plan culturel et religieux étaient
plus proches des talibans des américains
ou des occidentaux que nous étions alors
c'est là qu'on se rend compte finalement
que on est mieux de pas juger de laisser
ses préjugés de côté de tenter de porc
avoir un dut simpliste des événements et
ça m'a rendu beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins cynique aussi je pense qu'aux
journalistes parce que lorsqu'on voit
une femme par exemple qui a huit enfants
qui est réfugié là nord qui vit dans une
tente et qui est enceinte et qui a donné
sa neuvième enfant on se rend compte de
la vie finalement une résilience qu'on
soupçonne pas et qu'il faut respecter
ces choses là et tenter de simplement
rendre compte et c'est déjà quelque
chose et ça ça transformer votre façon
de travailler
je pense que oui parce que j'y allais
avec est beaucoup moins d'à priori et je
pense que ça m'a aidé à être plus à
l'écouté des gens qui l écoute des
situations des contextes convoi est donc
de savoir aussi que la vie n'est pas
perfectible que l'imperfection est
vraiment la norme et qu'il faut il faut
pas juger ou est trop trop demandant si
on veut
des gens concours vous qu'on croise sur
le chemin vous êtes par la suite quand
vous êtes rentré devenu directeur de
l'information alors que vous arriviez
donc de l'autre côté un peu de
l'équation sur le terrain est ce que
votre expérience sur le terrain à
influencer un peu la façon dont vous
avez dirigé dans un contexte où on était
en pleine une compression budgétaire
constamment à radio-canada est ce que ça
ça a influencé votre façon de voir votre
rôle comme directeur mais
instinctivement je me suis dit il faut
protéger les budgets de voyage qui
permettent à des journalistes comme vous
de d'aller sur le terrain pour un compte
de ce qu'on vit c'est sûr qu'on plane au
dessus d'une grosse structure qui a
beaucoup dit il ya beaucoup de coups il
ya beaucoup d'émissions il ya beaucoup
de services enfin je me suis dit il faut
continuer à privilégier le terrain parce
qu'on est les yeux et les oreilles du
public au fond les amène là où ils ne
peuvent pas aller et si on se prive de
sens prive de mission fondamentale de
radio canada lorsqu'elle six ans quelque
part mon expérience terrain m'a servi je
pense que c'est
c'est pour ça j'aurais quand même est
faible pour le reportage les choses ont
quand même beaucoup évolué en un court
laps de temps peut-être partir de
l'époque où vous vous étiez sur le
terrain la façon dont le terrain se
couvre maintenant évidemment il ya
toutes les nouvelles technologies les
réseaux sociaux aussi qui font
concurrence
et comment vous voyez cette évolution là
au début on essaie de tout faire
demandez aux gens il faut faire de la
radio de la télé du web est sur twitter
et tout cela on s'est rendu compte assez
rapidement que ont fait fausse route
mais cette approche l'heure et qu'il
fallait sortir un petit peu de cette
bulle du 140 caractères de twitter des
alertes
enfin il faut quand même le faire mais
que c'était plus important d'investir
dans leurs reportages de fond qui nous
permet de comprendre les enjeux dans son
compte que les gens ont soif de nouveau
de sorte que finalement l'instantanéité
de l'information
c'est avec nous maintenant pour
longtemps mais que ce n'est pas qui sort
que les gens ils veulent être au courant
de ce qui se passe immédiatement mais il
cherche aussi à comprendre le pourquoi
des choses
alors depuis quelques années surtout
avec le réinvestissement fédéral ça nous
a permis quand même de ré investir
davantage dans les longs reportages et
d'ailleurs le téléjournal se porte mieux
depuis que on vous permet à vous et à
d'autres de faire des reportages du 6 2
7 6 6 7 8 minutes qui amène les gens
avec vous sur le terrain pour comprendre
le sens des enjeux alors ça je pense que
c'est un passage important et je sens
pour rouler quand même sur la bonne
route avec cette approche et de façon
plus générale plus globale peut-être sur
la situation de l'information ici au
canada mais ailleurs dans le monde ce
danger là il existe encore le danger de
l'instantanéité les difficultés que ça
pose aux médias plus traditionnels qui
doivent de plus en plus justifier leur
existence qui sont si souvent accusée
d'être maintenant les porter de fausses
nouvelles
comment vous percevez un peu la
situation
c'est le grand défi du journalisme c'est
le grand défi démocratique aussi on
n'est pas les seuls joueurs là dedans
alors on vit dans une
dans un contexte de mes informations il
ya des fausses nouvelles évidemment les
gens qui tentent de manipuler les
nouvelles de façon façon volontaire mais
il ya aussi toutes sortes de fausses
informations qui circulent aussi
sur l'internet alors les gens aussi qui
s'informent seulement près de leurs amis
en se partageant chacun des déconvenues
qui sont pas vérifiées alors à travers
ça comment comment garder la pertinence
du journalisme et d'un diffuseur public
c'est le grand défi de notre époque et
c'est important et radio canada un jeu
rôle très important à jouer au moment où
les autres médias privés ont de la
difficulté à survivre financièrement
alors on se doit nous de s'assurer que
on est leader en crédibilité de
l'information en vérification des faits
de s'assurer qu'on explique davantage
comment on fonctionne c'est quoi les
choix qu'on fait parce qu'il faut
développer aussi une relation beaucoup
plus forte avec notre public
alors par exemple le fait qu'on vous
demande parfois de faire des facebook
live avec lié avec les publics leurs
souvenirs sur le terrain ça ce sont des
moyens qui nous permettent d'établir une
vraie relation avec le public et ça
c'est payant
mais on est dans une époque qui est
vraiment très très importante est
incertaine pour l'information et sa des
répercussions aussi sur la vie
démocratique parce que si on n'a pas de
journalisme fort qui est le chien de
garde des institutions publiques
ben c'est à ce moment là qu'on que tout
ça peut déraper
vous avez publié des essais
sur les banques principalement sur les
endroits que vous avez couvert au cours
de votre carrière vous parlez de vie
démocratique qu'est ce que ça vous le
constatez justement dans ce contexte là
une espèce de montée des populismes par
exemple là où il ya quand même danger
supplémentaire c'est beaucoup de ces
régimes se servent justement des réseaux
sociaux ou des nouveaux moyens de
l'internet justement pour non seulement
contourner les journalistes où la presse
est libre si on veut mais pour aussi
subjugué des populations en chine
maintenant les policiers se promènent
avec des verts qui permet d'identifier
les gens alors donc il ya des éléments
positifs facile d'éléments
technologiques lors il ya des éléments
qui sont négatifs alors c'est sûr que
tout ça a une influence sur la vie
démocratique et je dois dire que je
trouve un peu ironique après avoir parce
qu'on a fait aussi ensemble beaucoup
c'est de suivre un peu l'évolution des
sociétés dans ce contexte là en se
disant est ce que ces pays là iront
davantage vers le libéralisme au port et
maintenant la grande question c'est
est-ce que nos démocraties mêmes ne vont
pas déraper vers vers des modèles qui
sont moins libre alors qu'on pensait
tous que l'internet allait être le grand
libérateur finalement du xxème siècle
vous partent à la retraite
est-ce que vous avez des plans pour
l'avenir est ce que vous allez continuer
de vous intéresser à ces questions-là
d'information et de démocratie
je me dirige vers l'enseignement
universitaire vers l'édition un peu
l'écriture quand même de livres parce
que ça donne ce cette liberté là mais
j'ai aussi l'intention de m'impliquer
beaucoup dans la poursuite de cette
réflexion-là sur le journalisme est sûre
il de participer des groupes qui se
préoccupent de l'avenir du métier dans
un contexte plus large de démocratie
mais cinq ans mais merci vous en prie